[Music]
welcome to Dancing with the Stars I'm
Tom Bergeron and I'm Erin Andrews it's
most memorable year night lots of tears
Monday night as the season 20 forecast
reflected on the most challenging times
in their lives as they turn their
troubles into triumphs and expressed it
all through dance
[Music]
fifth harmony gave a surprise
performance during normanni Corday's
rumba her most memorable year 2012 when
she joined the girl group I feel like I
can't do enough to even think that I put
into words how grateful I actually have
for them just because they changed my
life former bachelor nick vile had an
assist from his fiance Vanessa
during his rumba with Peta Murgatroyd I
think she did fantastic actually we
rehearsed it a couple of times and we
were trying to time the dip and it was
easily our best dip NFL Pro Rashad
Jennings dedicated his contemporary
routine to his father growing up they
had a strange relationship any time you
try to get closer to him he would turn
to alcohol Rashad's performance was so
stunning it brought him and his father
to tears
he also nabbed the first tens of the
season obviously the scores shocked me I
mean I was surprised but honestly I
could have I could have got zero and I
still would feel as good as I do right
now because that was much more than a
dance to me that was me having poetry
emotion for Olympic gold medalist Simone
biles her most memorable year was 2000
the year she was adopted by her
biological grandparents it was exciting
to have them there and to go through it
with me I was just crying but I think
somewhere in like the mumbling worth I
love you 2016 was a scary year for
Bonner Bolton he broke his neck during a
bull riding competition
moment where you thought this is it memo
Ghana
[Music]
his Foxtrot with Sharna Burgess earned a
32 out of 40 from the judges we grew a
luck this week together it wasn't an
easy week this is so fresh this story
this happened a year ago and Here I am
saying let's do a dance about it that's
hard for someone to go okay I trust you
to do that and here is here's my heart
and soul that she's like to dance there
but ultimately one dancing pair was
eliminated the couple leaving right now
is mr. t and Kim
[Music]
you